so my name is supersonic I'm from the
University of Alan Goldberg and last
year I did a three months internship
report from and today I'm presenting
mark an example from that on iris
recognition okay so hello everyone
understanding I have done an internship
at work from last year and today I want
to talk a bit about one of the results
of that and that was a marketing example
on iris recognition and since Jan um as
a PhD student at the University of a
long-known back with the digital sports
group where I work on human movement
analysis in a medical context but let's
dive straight in so the table of
contents for today is of course we'll
look a bit off at the motivation of why
do iris recognition then I'll quickly
explain the data set I use and then go
over the methods of how actually to do
iris recognition and then we have to
identification schemes one year the
Hamming distance and one we are a
classification approach okay so iris
recognition has become some prizing lee
reliable in for example security
settings or law enforcement settings but
also in the onion identification of
paperless refugees and the most striking
example is maybe that of the Afghan girl
on the left here who ended up on the
cover of national Geographics in the 80s
and was actually identified by an iris
scan in 2004 and why from technology now
delivers all the building blocks to
build up in this an entire
proof-of-concept iris recognition system
and that is what we want to do today and
in doing so will basically follow the
paper down here so John darkman who is
sort of the Guru and iris recognition
wrote in invited paper titled how iris
recognition works and that was the basis
for for this presentation Morris so in
terms of data i use the noisy visible
wavelength
image database in buras that is provided
by the University of bearer and Portugal
and can be publically downloaded from
the web and it contains color images of
the human eye and in total we have about
1877 images from 241 participants we
have for each participant's 425 images
from two sessions one session was done
in a dark room to minimize the the
artifacts from reflections and change in
contrast and luminosity and such things
so we have 11 data said that it's really
high quality and then we have another
session in a more natural environment
reflecting all the problems you have
there for example at the airport and
then we do some simplifications for this
so we only look at the first two images
will use the first one for training and
the second Walter testing and we can
load an image here from the database and
it looks like this then the first thing
we'll do is we'll resize it quite a bit
to only 200 pixels because that makes
computation easier for us in terms of
time and also in RS recognition you
probably want to have it work at a
distance and then you do not have let
high resolution that you find on this
database and the last thing we do is we
only use a great channel okay so much
about the data let's look at the methods
so I put some of the code outside of the
notebook and just load that here first
we'll have to segment the IRS so
determine the boundaries of the iris and
the pupil then I'll talk a bit about
unfolding the iris pattern which we have
to do in order to get a commended
support for all the irises because yeah
basically you have to con air two
circles that don't share the same Center
and then you somehow have to compare the
EE patterns and do that in a way that is
consistent over the irises and then we
compute what's called iris codes with
lockable filters and these lock our
photos is a prototype
find it for 40 from last year so explain
surely what the low carbon filters are
and how they relate to two carbon
filters which some of you might know um
yeah then we'll go through the iris code
actually and in the end to the batch
processing on the entire data set to
draft the iris codes for every
participant okay so how do we get the
boundaries of the pupil and the and the
iris from here so basically what we'll
do is we'll use a template that looks
like this and that captures the change
in contrast from the sclera here to the
iris and then also from the RS to the
pupil and the method will use is
essentially a gradient descent on the
response to this template where we then
estimate the the center of this circular
structure by the highest highest
response and then also need the radios
by just the radius of this template that
we can adjust and then we can run such a
segmentation here takes a few seconds
and then we can look at the result and
then you see okay the segmentation seems
to work we can also look at the the
progress of the segmentation so if I
press play here then okay first we
refined the errors and then we resumed
into the pupil and so one thing to
notice that this is of course a very you
know very straightforward technique to
to the segmentation of these these
structures and it didn't work on all the
images so it only worked on line 21
images from the training subside on 70
from the testing subset and I because
the project was not about segmentation
of these DRS and the pupil i just select
these data sets to to work on them in
the remainder of the talk
okay then as I said earlier now we have
these two two circles and need to
basically compared to iris patterns and
what we do is we convert them to a
dimensionless polar coordinate system
and we can assemble some positions here
and then show them on the image so
basically what we do is we sample eight
points radially in between the two
boundaries and then angularly you have
128 samples and then we can put it on
the function here so we'll assemble
these positions he and then use image
value and airy shape to to get the
pattern out and then plot that for
example array plottin and then we have
such a pattern here from from this RS
and the iris code is now basically
answering a question of condensing this
pattern to a very compact form that we
can easily compare and we do that with
lochaber filters they were first
proposed by David Shea field this
publication here and already from the
title you can guess that the motivation
was somehow related to statistics and
natural images and in contrast to the
gobble filter so I've here on the top
row the new la cava filter in the domain
and in the spatial domain over here and
then GABA further he also threw in
meinen in spatial domain and the first
thing to notice is that the lock our
photo is constructed with a logarithmic
rescaling of the axis of spatial
frequency so that would be radial if
you're not in the one-dimensional case
and because of that it's non symmetric
around its center frequency here and
that then makes the colonel more
spatially localized as you can see here
so the La Cava kernel is especially bit
more localized in the garba colonel but
most importantly the lockable kernel
will be less sensitive in a 2-2 changes
in contrast because it does not pick any
d pick up any DC component so as we go
to zero frequency hear the response
drops down to zero whereas in the gamma
photon is
of something left and that's
particularly important for for this iris
recognition application where you don't
want your features to be contrast
dependent so then if we go to the iris
codes will use these kind of filters in
1d along the angular direction of the
pattern and we'll have an even in a lot
further part that we use for
demodulation of the pattern and then
will encode the face and the the phase
encoding scheme is shown here so
whenever the even part is positive we've
got a one here and whenever it's
negative we get a 0 here and then for
each pixel in this in this RS patch we
get sort of one complex bit that is just
these needs two numbers here and then
we'll just rifle them together to get a
code that is angularly twice as long as
the iris pattern that we had before we
do that here in this functions or iris
code with rowen the iris pattern and
some parameters for the filter so
basically the the wavelength that
corresponds to the center frequency and
bandwidth factor and then the face
quantization is done with the unit step
so whenever it's positive we'll get one
whenever it's negative we go to zero and
then in this list table here we compute
the filter response for each row to have
an angularly and also for the even and
odd part and then down here we just
drive her together the even and odd part
of the filter and then we can do that
for an example here and again we see
this is iris pattern that we just had
here and then also this code which is
now a binary code and in that is quite
effective which we want for example to
compare two codes or also to store it or
so it's it's a very compact descriptor
of the pattern so it's left now and
methods is the batch processing so there
we'll just load in our data directory
and then I hear the selection for the
raining in tests that are manually
selected so the cases where the
segmentation words that I can load the
images do the segmentations without
which I yeah just saved in the seas for
five th goes that actually took some
time then we can quickly test if the
segmentation worked so for this image it
work and let's check another one for
example one yeah looks also fine then we
do the unfolding so we use this iris
pattern function and here we compute the
DRS codes okay now we have the iris
codes for the training and test data set
and can play around a bit or that so the
first identification scheme we want to
look at is identification via at the
Hamming distance and just as a reminder
what is the Hamming distance so having
distance give the Hamming distance not
very descriptive so maybe let's look at
the details here and here it says okay
Lee Hamming distance gives the number of
elements whose values disagree in U and
V so basically the number of of pixels
worth two codes disagree and with that
we can already identify a person but we
need to have some sort of decision
boundary to say okay this is since we
can consider two we can consider the
code to be actually the one that we're
we have on the database and if the
distance is a bit larger than say okay
this is not the person we are looking
for and to get this decision boundary we
look at imposters for this authentics on
the database so in this training and
test data set that we have and we have
to normalize for inconsistent iris
orientations in the input image set so
we could either rotate the input images
but now as we have the codes we could
also just compare cyclic angular shifts
of the code which is computationally
much more efficient and what we'll do
we'll compare eight different
orientations and then just keep the best
fit for so we basically rotate
add on and keep the best best fit over
these eight rotations entering large
populations will test the training set
against the test set and vice versa so
here we have the angular shift so we
want to shift eight times so this is the
model that we have to shift and then
here we test the training against the
test data set keep the best fit over the
cyclic shift so with the men here over
this table where we then compute the
Hamming distance for these two codes
here one is the code from the test set
and the other one is a rotated version
of code from the training set and the
training said we'll just limit to the
cases that that is not the current code
that we put here and then we basically
do the same for for training against
tests so we can evaluate this and then
we do the same for the authentics where
we limit the code that we put here to be
exactly the the code from the training
set that we select here so we do the
same here evaluate that and then we can
plot histograms for both and we have
here the normalized Hamming distance so
from 0 to 1 for the imposters and the
authentics and for the imposter it looks
quite good because we have a lot of iris
comparisons and the distribution is
quite sharp so we can say ok if we draw
our decision boundary somewhere here and
we're probably quite good on the
authentic side we're a bit short of
virus comparisons so we have only 140
but the general trend seems seems
reasonable so it's more likely to peek
somewhere around 0 point 25 then this
point 46 here and then we can actually
look at the results for some decision
boundaries so we're just sample decision
boundaries here and count the number of
of instances where for example the
impulses are below or above this this
decision boundary and also the
authentics and then we get
for these Hamming distance criteria here
get the false positives rates and false
negatives rates have to find some some
good match between the two where we now
actually want to draw this decision
boundary s Orry said we're a bit short
on on data and dortmund reports results
on a database of about 1 million iris
codes and you can maintain false match
probabilities as low as 10 to minus 6
with this approach so it's actually
quite powerful the second thing that we
want to do is do the identification via
classification that we can basically do
two things you can either throw the iris
code directly into classify or we can
just use the raw images without any
feature extraction because the iris code
is basically a feature of the input
image and will first look at the iris
code so we're just compute classifiers
for set of methods here and then look at
the at the detection rights and then
just choose the classifier with the best
detection rate which in this case is
support vector machine and then we can
have a look at the results in detail so
I'm will come up with this big table
here where we have a recognized ID and a
true ID and whenever to match ok I'll
color it green but when they don't match
I am colored in red and I show the
segmentation for this ID and for this ID
and also the codes and the Hamming
distance is here to the training set for
all the test images and also where these
two IDs are in this power point cloud so
true ID is somewhere here and the
recognize that need somewhere here and
here you can already see ok it's
probably an issue with segmentation I
might had to discard this list image in
the first place because the segmentation
does not does not actually match and
then down here we have a second case
where yeah ok it's probably the same
issue so the segmentation some really
good here and third case here
where to be honest I don't really know
where the the mismatch comes from one
thing could be that of course in this
segmentation if you would do it properly
you of course had to also mask away the
eyelids here because those don't really
belong to your iris pattern and yeah you
would have to work more than
segmentation probably to make this work
and bit better but we can have a look at
the detection right again so we had
ninety-five percent for this and fourth
match or false positive rate is only
four percent which is actually quite
good if you know only throw in the raw
images or without any processing then we
can again do this for a bunch of of
methods and we'll get the detection
rates oops and then we see that okay the
best one is nearest neighbors what if
guess I born but the detection rate is
only about eighty seven percent so on
the extraction of this very compact
feature did make sense in the first
place and also if we think about scaling
the whole thing to to the scale that
that dogmen reports his results on
having these codes in this binary format
is very efficient because you can
compare them very efficiently as
compared to if you would just turn it on
the input images okay that we offer me
thank you for attention